derrière le cash ça doit rester ouvert
10/10 d'acuité visuelle donc pour cette
adolescente
tout va bien en revanche pour malika
huit ans rendez vous chez
l'ophtalmologiste est nécessaire parce
que tu as déjà été bon en ophtalmologie
et alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
sont des enfants qui n'ont pas de
référence et qui du coup ne se plaignent
pas auprès de leurs parents sur leur
mauvaise vision parfois
on voit les enfants qui traînent un
petit peu sur les lettres parce qu'ils
ont envie effectivement de porter des
lunettes parce que le copain ou la
copine emporte oui mais ça se décerne la
lune est neutre aussi peut avoir son
importance puisque nous sommes dans une
société qui est très connectés et les
enfants en fixe beaucoup ces appareils
met une longueur d'onde de lumière bleue
et le fait d'avoir une lunette ne te
permet d'être équipé avec l'anti of la
lumière bleue pour garder l'oeil ont
recours depuis 13 ans maintenant
la fcpe la fédération des conseils de
parents d'élèves en partenariat avec les
opticiens de lille organise plusieurs
journées de dépistage visuel avant la
rentrée des classes
un dépistage gratuit les troubles de la
vision sont souvent responsables de
difficultés dans l'apprentissage une vue
déficiente en début d'année n'est pas
forcément perçue avant le mou la fin du
premier trimestre et quand le jeune
se rend compte de cela il est l'année
scolaire est quasiment terminée quand il
ya la possibilité de prendre rendez vous
chez un opticien tutelle notamment
un opticien et donc par rapport à cela
on en propose de pouvoir
ils ont décelé 6 ha oui ou non
souci je suis venu parce que j'ai une
information et je me suis dit que c'est
une opportunité car obtenir un rendez
vous chez un ophtalmo ce n'est pas
évident près de 250 enfants et
adolescents de 6 à 20 ans ont consulté
l'année dernière dans le cadre de cette
opération